un drôle de mot rock and roll
mais c'est rock and roll signifie que Beethoven
était rock and roll et il est temps tu sais que
tu ne pouvais pas entendre tu sais qu'il joue
très fort tu sais jouer jouer sur 10
sur 10 tu sais
Alan Vega tu ne penses pas  que tu es
le dernier rockeur sur Terre non
pourquoi ce seront d'autres
qui descendront tu sais après moi toujours
c'est de ça qu'il s'agit n'est-ce pas nous dire
ce qui marche je n'en ai aucune idée oui
je suis sûr que toi non je n'en ai aucune idée  mec d'où
venez-vous de New York que
faisiez-vous à New York avant de faire du
rock and roll euh grandir grandir
Staying Alive comment as-tu rencontré Martin
Reeve par accident et l'as-tu rencontré dans
la rue comme ça c'est juste
ici  ouais cherche toujours à le rencontrer
tu ne penses pas que le bébé de jukesberg
restera dans le Hall of Fame du rock
and roll pour toujours oui pourquoi parce que c'est
bon
juste bon c'est juste bon ouais je veux dire
c'est aussi bon que tout ce qui est
là  des personnes ont été
inspirées par vous vous connaissez  on leur a beaucoup volé
ils ont beaucoup volé Ouais
Ouais je suppose que c'est quand
même bien
à propos de cette longue chute de
noms nah quoi pour l'homme tu sais
tu connais tous les noms que je devrais te dire
au revoir tu veux dire ouais je suis un
ange tu es un déguisement d'ingénieur je
pense pourquoi à l'époque le suicide s'est séparé
nous n'avons jamais  nous avons juste pris un peu de split mais
tu as dit que tu es né avec Martin en utilisant
euh Cintas tout le temps et tu n'as jamais
eu de guitares je n'ai jamais dit que lui quand le
sien tu sais qu'il est né avec moi aussi si
c'est le cas ce n'est pas une question  des
guitares et des synthétiseurs viennent d'être interrogés
avec différentes musiques tu sais tu sais
Alan tu quittes la légende du rock and
roll mais très peu de gens écoutent ta
musique comment tu en
penses je ne sais pas c'est définitivement leur
malchance tu sais c'est  euh c'est leurs
problèmes pas les
miens non  écoutez un jour vous pensez que le
vrai Rock and Roller devrait être un perdant
euh non le gagnant
pourquoi un perdant je veux dire quelle est l'idée d'un
perdant qui est toxicomane euh ouais non pas
du tout je veux dire je ne pense pas qu'aucun d'eux ne
perde  Je pense que le voyage est si difficile que
tu sais que tu atterris à boire et à te
droguer et tout juste pour essayer de
rester en vie dans un sens tu sais que tu
sembles être en très bonne santé non je suis
toi-même ouais j'ai commencé à manger tu sais
je '  j'ai appris à manger en France
et Libération ouais beaucoup
te soutiennent beaucoup oui tu en penses quoi
je les aime mec tu sais je
pense que bayonne c'est le meilleur critique du
monde tu sais vraiment c'est super
Libération c'est super c'est super journal
tu as des pages entières à chaque fois dans
liberation ben je le mérite tu le mérites
pas vraiment je plaisante mais le mien est
gris mais tu ne trouves pas que c'est terrible
de se sentir comme un bon artiste authentique
et d'être obligé de voyager en  une camionnette
d'un club à l'autre parfois ouais
certains  des fois ça devient dur mais d'autres fois
tu te sens mal parfois ouais
parfois ils sont très excités ça
dépend de ce qu'est ma vie à l'
époque tu sais en ce moment c'est
agréable c'est comme si je serais à Paris pendant 10
jours  c'est super c'est le bon côté
tu sais alors il y a le mauvais côté donc
c'est comme la vie tout n'est pas une
chose tu sais c'est l'un ou l'autre tu
sais peut-être que tu es trop avanga tu ne
penses pas non pas du tout trop en retard
en fait personne ne pourrait être dans le futur
juste le reste du monde vit dans
le passé c'est tout
ce que tu penses du rock and roll aujourd'hui
c'est assez terrible tu ne penses pas que je
ne pense plus qu'il y ait de rock and roll en
fait  tu sais mais ça
change ça change pour rapper vers d'autres
choses tu sais qui est le rock and roll le
rock and roll est un langage pour les gens
qui aiment vouloir tu sais avoir quelque chose de
fort à dire sur la vie ou quelque chose alors
tu sais que c'est un drôle de mot rock  et rouler
mais c'est du rock  mèmes d roll Beethoven
était rock and roll à son époque tu sais
qu'il ne pouvait pas entendre tu sais qu'il joue
très fort tu sais jouer en jouant sur 10
sur 10 tu sais comme euh ces groupes en
10. pourquoi aimes-tu tellement Paris
oh  c'est une ville très cool c'est une super
ville c'est beau visuellement la nourriture
est super les femmes sont super il y a du
bruit dans la ville n'est-ce pas parce que les
gens délirent de toi ici non non
j'étais amoureux de Paris avant d'être ici
en  Paris avant d'être Alan Vega tu sais
ce que je veux dire ouais je venais et
j'adorais toujours ça c'est juste que j'aime la culture
tu connais Paris pour moi eh bien ce n'est pas seulement
Paris la France beaucoup les écrivains j'aime
kamu et soft et tu sais tout ça
chose que les peintres j'ai toujours j'ai toujours
aimé ça depuis que je suis petit j'ai
toujours aimé la culture française je ne sais pas
pourquoi ne me demandez pas vous savez mes parents
ne sont pas français ou quoi que ce soit mais alors quand je suis
venu à Paris en premier  l'endroit
où je suis jamais venu était Paris quand je suis venu d'Amérique, j'ai
toujours adoré  ça y est je n'ai pas
tu regardes parfois l'étoile Vega ouais
ouais bien sûr combien de fois pas trop souvent
tu ne peux plus la voir c'est trop nuageux
tout le temps l'air est tout pollué maintenant
je ne peux plus voir mais quand tu vois
qu'en pensez-vous oh c'est une belle
étoile c'est probablement que vous savez qu'ils ont
découvert des planètes autour de l'étoile
il y a probablement une vie humaine il y avait
une sorte de vie autour de cette
étoile vous pensez que vous irez là-bas un jour
je pourrais venir de là
qui sait  tu ne sais pas tu sais